Хімічні заводи завбільшки, як невелике місто.
Їм потрібні мільярди кіловат-годин. Економіка Німеччини потребує величезної кількості енергії.
Але зараз її не вистачає, і коштує вона дорожче, ніж будь-коли.
Особливо на більш енергоємних технологічних етапах ми вже сьогодні спостерігаємо помітне зниження обсягів виробництва.
Сталеливарні заводи, важка промисловість, машинобудування
- для багатьох підприємств зупинка постачання російського газу може мати катастрофічні наслідки.
Справа в тому, що цього разу не всіх можна буде врятувати.
Тож час економічного розквіту Німеччини позаду? Невже зникнуть цілі галузі? Як можна протистояти цьому?
Криза прискорює трансформацію, яка була у будь-якому випадку неминуча.
Промисловість Німеччини - надзвичайно енергоємна.
Дуже швидке зростання цін на газ та електроенергію особливо позначається на хімічній промисловості.
Хімічна галузь споживає близько третини загального обсягу енергії, яка потрібна для промисловості.
Це понад тисячу мільярдів кіловат-годин.
За нею йдуть металургія, нафтопереробка, виробництво скла, паперу та продуктів харчування.
Для багатьох підприємств термін дії старих контрактів на постачання енергоносіїв та електрики закінчується наприкінці року.
Нові умови - це шок.
У деяких випадках називаються вкрай високі ціни на електроенергію та газ,
з якими просто неможливо далі виробляти жодну продукцію,
починаючи від миючих засобів та закінчуючи фармацевтичними препаратами, клеями та іншими товарами.
Зрештою вони виготовляються з хімічної сировини. І це зачепить весь ланцюжок утворення вартості хімічної продукції не пізніше наступного року.
Хімічний концерн BASF раніше отримував половину необхідного для виробництва газу з Росії.
Ще на початку 1990-их спільно з російською держкомпанією "Газпром" BASF побудував газопровід до своєї штаб-квартири у Людвігсгафені
на південному заході Німеччини. Також концерн фінансово підтримав будівництво газопроводу "Ямал" через Польщу до Німеччини.
З 2008 року компанія брала участь і у будівництві "Північного потоку-1".
Натомість російський газ надходив на підприємство за особливо низькими цінами.
Першою помилкою було продовжувати збільшувати залежність від Росії, навіть після анексії Криму.
Друга велика помилка полягає в тому, що ми просто проспали розвиток відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Хоча ці технології доступні вже десять років, вони ефективні та дешеві, ми пригальмували, і тепер це приносить свої плоди.
Тож це і наша помилка в Німеччині, що криза зараз настільки глибока і що економіка перебуває в небезпеці.
Газ також використовується для вироблення електроенергії у Німеччині.
Електроенергія тут набагато дорожча, ніж в інших країнах.
Доводиться платити зараз майже 32 центи за кіловат-годину - середній показник у світі становить лише 12 центів.
Дорога енергія стає проблемою для малих і середніх підприємств, що залежать від експорту.
Досі саме завдяки їм Німеччина проходила через усі кризи, вигравала від глобалізації.
Без дешевої енергії німецька продукція стане надто дорогою на світовому ринку. То який же вихід?
Енергетичний перехід і зелена трансформація, безперечно, є чудовою можливістю зробити щось позитивне з цієї кризи.
Вони можуть і повинні допомогти нам справді знову стати лідерами як індустріальна країна,
як країна інженерів, коли йдеться про сталість і відновлювані джерела енергії.
Німецьким компаніям необхідно перебудуватися, інвестувати у нові технології та енергоефективність,
вкладати у дослідження та розвиток. А державі необхідно терміново розширити енергомережі та інфраструктуру.
Німецькі та європейські компанії мають створити перевагу в галузі технологій.
Більш дорога енергія у наступні 5-10 років має сприйматися не як недолік.
Потрібно стати настільки передовими в галузі технологій, щоб з гаком компенсувати вищі витрати на електроенергію.
Перебудова економіки - одне з найважчих завдань у найближчі кілька років.
Часу залишається зовсім небагато.